well let's talk now about health care
because that is an issue in the
background and forefront of what's going
on politically in the u.s. right now
yesterday Senate Republicans I told you
we're working on this American Health
Care Act version two which had already
been passed by the house I guess at this
point it's been what four to six weeks
ago or something like that now as of
yesterday nobody had seen this bill even
most Republicans hadn't seen the bill
because it was the aides to 13 senators
involved in this group drafting this
version two of the American Health Care
Act that had been working on it behind
closed doors this is what I told you
yesterday Donald Trump did another one
of these weird campaign style rallies
this one and none other than Cedar
Rapids Iowa and he was blaming Democrats
for obstruction as to why'd the bill
that not even other Senate Republicans
had seen yesterday was may be in
jeopardy before it even went public
again nobody even knew what the bill was
here's Trump view votes seriously a few
votes from the Democrats it could be so
easy and so beautiful and you'd have
cooperation right and their plan isn't
working because they thought they were
going to win last night in Atlanta they
thought they were going to
[Music]
but the plan was ultimately released
this morning I believe at 10:50 a.m.
Eastern Time this was of course from
last night it plan is about a hundred
and forty pages I was able to get
through the first 30 or 35 pages before
we started working on today's show
a beautiful health care plan Trump talks
about where is the beauty in tens of
millions of people losing coverage some
ending up dead
some ending up using the emergency room
as their primary care ultimately leaving
hospital bills unpaid which then make
people who have health insurances
premiums even higher it's not Democrats
that that are obstructing here that have
been no one had seen the bill Pat I mean
these Trump isms really don't help
either when he talks about you know the
House bill being mean and then this new
one having you know beauty in heart it
just not the appropriate setting I would
say it's total and utter nonsense and
yesterday Republican senator bob Corker
from tennessee said to the new york
times quote the process is better if you
do it in public and that people get
buying along the way and understand
what's going on obviously that's not the
route that is being taken I told you
yesterday Republican senator from
Kentucky Rand Paul said to NBC News
quote I think it's being written up by
someone somewhere but I'm not aware of
who or where if you get a copy will you
send me a copy not just Democrats right
Republicans saying we don't agree with
the process we don't know what the
substance is and what has leaked about
the Senate bill I guess what's been
released now is that it is very similar
to the one passed in the house last
month the one in the house the
Congressional Budget Office scored it as
estimating 23 million fewer people would
be able to have health care coverage
under that bill forget about the health
care bill for a second let's think about
what Trump is saying Republicans have
total control of Congress right now
they've got the White House they've got
the Senate they've got the house they're
4 for 4 in special election since Donald
Trump's election in November this entire
Democrats obstructing us thing from
Trump is a total ruse if Trump can't get
the Mexican wall done it's on him it's
on Republicans if Trump can't
health care what he calls a fix I don't
believe it's a fix I think it'd be
further breaking the system it's on
Republicans and I was actually listening
to UM Georgia voter interviews we had
that Georgia sixth congressional
district special election earlier this
week where John Asif was narrowly
defeated and I was listening to NPR a
couple days ago pat and they're
interviewing voters who are voting in
the election and a guy identified as a
supposed
independent voter said I'm voting for
the Republican karen handel in the
special election because I don't like
the obstruction from Democrats it works
this is so transparently bogus but it
works it's it's I don't want to say 1984
asked better better said probably brave
new world era type brainwashing and it's
working on people he also has to get his
own party in order to because you have
people attacking it from the center like
Lisa Murkowski like Susan Collins right
and then you have people on the far
right like Rand Paul and Mike Lee who
think that it doesn't go far enough in
repealing Obamacare and sadly it's
disproportionately red state
right-wingers who are going to get
screwed everyone will get screwed there
will be no shortage of progressives
moderates independent right everybody's
going to get screwed there's going to be
no shortage of scrooge from this but
blue states do have better
infrastructure and better funded social
programs so it's going to be
disproportionately trump voters who
voted for Trump partially to anger
liberals who are going to end up getting
screwed here and and by not only this
and by other Republican policies as well
and you know they're still going to
blame Democrats Pat even though they
control every aspect of government and
most state legislatures as well yeah if
you live in a red state and are at risk
of losing your health care we invite you
to move to a blue state like here in
Massachusetts you know also all that
would also help increase our democratic
representation for the next go-around
right well that's a complex Pat speaking
for himself on that one folks let's not
uh I mean I've also talked about how
blue Staters should actually move to the
narrow red states to try to turn those
blue I mean there's a number of ways to
pardon the the horrific pun skin a cat
which neither pad or I would ever do but
in any case a broader conversation for a
different day send me your thoughts
about what we now know of
version two of the AHCA in the Senate
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman you can
follow the show at david pakman show
today's sponsor is taga dab the hosting
specialist whatever your hosting needs
for your business or project taga dab
can do it dedicated servers virtual
private servers cloud server solutions
colocation custom server solutions and
the big thing at taga dab is their
customer support over 70% of their
business comes from repeat orders and
recommendations from existing customers
this is a testament to the great support
that they give their customers currently
rated a nine point seven out of ten
according to the Trustpilot
review system with a growing number of
people interested in moving their
businesses and projects to the cloud
taga dab currently offers our viewers
and listeners a twenty british pound
free credit about twenty four US dollars
to all new customers that sign up gives
you a chance to try the service this is
a limited availability offer for the
viewers and listeners of the David
Pakman show
to take advantage go to sign up CagA Deb
comm /t DPS and use the offer code TDPS
20 during account registration support
our sponsors and support our show in
doing so sign up ta ga da be com /t DPS
coupon code is TDPS 20